có cung ứng rồi anh hành hải và nhiều vấn đề anh đến trường thống và phía trường thống khác cũng sẽ được tạo lần tại sangrila.
Vìa sangrila mới tổn bị thư chú tính nước pháp biểu rất đẹp.
Đi chó thấy bái trò vị thế y tính ngày càng cao của Vietnam cũng như của đồng chí tổn bị thư chú tính nước tổn lắm.
Vìa năm hiện được in nhật là một đêm ký tế hội nhập sâu dầu, nhưng vẫn dự vấn tự chú chính lật.
Một cuốc gia đang phát triển năng đầu có khát vọng gên lên mạnh mẽ.
Đồng thời là thành viên tích cửa cho chắc dẫn của cộng đồng cuốc tế và cu vật.
Dúng ta, chúng ta, chúng ta vọng rằng vui bài pháp biểu của đồng chí tổn bị thư chú tính nước tổn lắm.
Tại gên đoạn đổi pho anh sangrila đây này thì sẽ chuyển đi một thống điểm và những quán điểm của Vietnam.
Về đi hướng, chiến lượng để vấn dài quyết các cái vấn đề nổi lên trong khoả trình chuyển dịch cổ tục của khu vật và cuối tế.
Lối thoại sangrila là dễn đàn Anh Ninh hàng đầu cuốc vật cho á thái mình dân.
Zó vẹn nghiên cứu chỉ lợ cuốc tế tổ chức thử miền tại Singapore.
Cuối tụi nhiều nhờ lãnh nào bự trường cuốc phòng học giả và chuyên gia chỉ lợh hàng đầu thế giới.
Đây là dễn đàn có ý tính vài ngừng lớn đối với các lãnh đều hoa mình Anh Ninh và cổ trước cuốc vật.